in this video we're about to react to AI
generated images of Attack on Titan
what's going on people my name is Turtle
Quirk aka the guy who speaks way too
much about Attack on Titan and in this
video you and I are about to go through
this series of videos that essentially
has Attack on Titan characters and
situations generated you know like a
realistic way through AI
um but yeah let's just get into it okay
so we see Peak this is
interesting okay first of all does she
look good yes does she look how I would
imagine she would look in real life I'm
gonna say no but it is it it's still
interesting it's interesting to look at
um yeah okay nine out of ten let's go
let's let's keep going okay so we see an
image of rhino what's he gonna look like
in real life oh glow up okay Ronnie
looks really good even if you look at
the phasia hair like it's perfect this
is basically what he would look like I
guess the only thing that would be
different is his eye color like I don't
remember him having blue eyes ever but
besides the eye color this looks this
looks on point man this is this stuff is
really good so we've seen Peak we've
seen Reiner Connie okay it's Connie time
based on the last two I feel like this
is going to be really good let's have a
look
okay I don't like this one that's not
Connie bro who is that he looks like
baby Elvis that did not look like Connie
okay okay Jean is up next
yeah okay that that looks like John that
looks like John his face looks a bit
like a mouse rather than a horse because
you know everyone says all the
characters always say how John looks
like a horse but this guy here
definitely more mouse-like than
horse-like another thing I like about
this even the lighting of him being in
pods right that looks perfect right so
yeah well done to the AI okay this is
the one we've all been waiting for
Mikasa what does she look like okay yeah
so she so this doesn't really look like
a human
um all the other ones kind of look like
a real could be a real human like her
head shape looks kind of insane on the
right hand side or like the realistic
version doesn't really look that
realistic like I don't think a real
person would look like this but when you
compare the images side by side that it
does it did get the hairstyle perfect
like the hair looks exactly the same as
it does in the anime so it's just it's
cool it's cool Levi is next let's see
how Captain Levi looks yeah that's good
that's real good I like that one a lot
it does it did the bandage is perfect
the stitches on his face perfect as well
like yeah this is how he would really
look I I believe that how is it actually
making it real life isn't it oh
Aaron and yamir that is perfect no that
is really great the perfect thing about
this is that you know how like Aaron
Emir like you can't quite see their eyes
this embodies that perfectly like you
can't see their eyes it's like their
Hollow like like they don't have a soul
it's what it looks like it's yeah
amazing okay it's Annie and kyomi
ah okay it does a lot of things right so
for example we can see kiyomi's tears
those are done really you know it's all
the little details they're all there
when it comes to Annie I mean it's not
like a perfect adaptation of how I
thought she would look I guess the nose
is kind of similar they did it did do
the nose right and the hair basically
everything is just I I guess I guess it
is good okay it is good I don't know do
you guys think this is what Annie would
look like in real life I kind of feel
like there's just something a little bit
tiny bit off about it but it looks
fantastic but is it Annie though if I
looked at this person would I look at
them and say oh you look exactly like
Annie from Attack on Titan probably not
but it looks great still it's just it
just doesn't look exactly like Annie
okay we got to uh we're going to Ryder's
mom now oh yeah that's really good in it
it really captures like you know she's
stressed out at this point like this
scene that this is taken from is from
when she's you know they're they're
fighting for their lives they're trying
to escape from the rumbling and in the
realistic image image on the right hand
side you can see like the stress in her
face like the lines on her forehead her
like the wrinkles like she just seems
really stressed out not just about the
rumbling but also about Reiner being
dead potentially oh okay so this scene
is of the colossals approaching
okay I don't think I don't think that
one works so this is the scene where the
colossals are yeah literally like about
to trample Mali yeah it doesn't look as
realistic as it should so what we got
next hanji okay what does hanji look
like in AI
hey
okay well done okay so Mika and Annie
you know the reason why I don't think
this looks like Annie is because the
girl in the AI she just looks too soft
like the real Annie She's Like a
battle-harden Warrior like even when
she's crying even when she's upset you
just you just need to look at her and
you're like damn like she's been through
some stuff
with this character here I don't feel
like she's I don't feel like she's
killed 30 people or 100 people however
many however many people Annie has
killed I don't think this girl could do
that do the things that Annie did oh but
Ryan is back again yeah that looks like
him but he looks he does so much better
looking in real life in anime he's just
like a loser
like he's just like oh that's just
writer over there but like in the AI
image it's like oh damn that's Reiner
looking good but yeah
they they definitely gave him an upgrade
but it still looks like him
okay okay here's Connie and Armin Connie
and almond what are they gonna
oh that looks like Armin a lot yeah okay
I like this I like this that looks like
almond exactly
Connie I don't think so 10 out of 10 for
the Almond part of the image but for the
Connie part this is like if you bought
Connie from a garage sale like it
doesn't it just doesn't look like honey
like if you if you just showed me this
image I wouldn't guess that it was
Connie I think it looks more like Levi
than it does than it looks like Connie
following that we have Mikasa in
shiganshana and this is mikasurer as a
kid so let's see how this looks yeah
yeah that's really that's amazing
actually I do find it funny though how
the AI changed the walls like the actual
giant walls introduce this tiny little
brick wall here like it was just any old
wall that you could just climb over that
is funny but yeah besides the brick wall
the rest of it looks on point oh okay
next up is kid Aaron Young Aaron as a
kid crying and he looks like
he looks like the Antichrist I think he
looks creepy the way he's looking
directly into your eyes is freaky Ramsay
and Hillel are up next oh yeah
that is great they got everything down
the plants in the background here like
those have really been brought to life
and even the tree itself like the bit
down here uh with the with the leaves
the details are on point so this next
scene is of Aaron and Ramsay yeah that's
just creepy why do his tears look so
solid though that is strange and
Ramsay's hair is kind of like green I
guess the lighting in the original scene
kind of tricks the computer into
thinking that his hair was green In This
Moment yeah this one this one is a bit
creepy to me okay so we got some
colossal Titans coming up I don't have
high hopes for this so the body the body
of the Colossal Titans actually does
look pretty good the faces though when
we look at these colossal faces those
are literally just 2D images taken from
the anime itself like that's not 3D
that's a 2D image that it took from the
anime and just like superimposed onto
this 3D colossal body so needs a little
bit of work
aired and almond and pods this is going
to be a good one I think oh yeah the
pause tree look at that pause tree in
the back that is something else look at
that I have no words I just yeah that
pause tree is exactly what you would
want to see from something like this and
also the the sand as well everything I
feel like this could be
um if there was an attack on Titan movie
you know about the rumbling I feel like
this could be the poster Yelena this is
going to be interesting are they going
to do the bowl cut Justice
I don't like you know you know why I
don't like this the other net is not
meant to be good looking she was able to
pass for a guy people believe that she
was a guy just because she had this
little like this tiny beard if you put
that tiny beard on Angelina Jolie would
you think she's a man probably not I
think Jana is meant to look at least a
little bit manly because I don't believe
that anyone would look at the person on
the right and think she was a guy just
because she had a fake beard you know so
for that reason alone this does not look
like Eleanor on yankapon okay this
better be good this better be good
why is he posing like that though he's
posing like uh I don't know like he's in
a cover shoot or something like that on
the left is like this is a guy doing a
serious job working under serious time
constraints he's got sweat coming off
his face and on the right you have this
guy who's just like I don't believe that
his country is about to get trampled and
that he's doing everything he can to
stop it he just looks like he's just
like posing for the cameras Commander
Irvin I am I'm looking forward to seeing
what this looks like because every time
people talk about you know who could
play Irvin who would be a good Commander
Evan everyone always says Chris Evans
you know his name always comes up as
Commander Irvin
so I feel like because this AI is taking
images from the internet I'm guessing
that's what it does I imagine that what
we're about to see is Chris Evans or
someone who looks similar to Chris Evans
but let's have a look okay I take
everything I just said back that looks
nothing like Chris Evans but it doesn't
look like Irvin ah the hair does
everything else I'm gonna say no I don't
think that guy looks like Urban although
look at look at the outfit though the
outfit this AI does get certain things
right the outfit is always on point the
hair is usually always on point that
doesn't look like Urban to me but at
least everything else looks good okay
we're zooming in on Sasha the back of
Sasha's head
okay that that does look like the back
of Sasha's head is that the final one is
that the last yeah that was the last one
okay personally I've never seen the live
action movies so for me this was like
the most realistic depiction I've ever
seen of Attack on Titan yeah there were
a few ones that weren't that great
especially when it came to the Titans
themselves but for Reiner for Armin
there were a lot of them that were just
like wow this is a perfect like they
couldn't be any better but yeah let me
know what you guys think in the comments
down below also give this channel a look
it's called cozies they only have like
600 subscribers so they deserve more
than that I think like this is really
really entertaining so give them a shout
the Link's in the description to check
the channel out and uh yeah until the
next one peace out